well we're bringing Star Wars to life in
a big way and I mean really big we're
creating a jaw-dropping new world that
represents our largest single themed
land expansion ever now we knew it
needed to be big we knew it needed to be
great and we knew it needed to be every
bit as thrilling as the films are going
to be so we're going to transport guests
to a whole new planet the land will be
real and authentic and every encounter
will bring more of the Star Wars story
to life than ever before this new 14
acre land will be occupied by many
inhabitants humanoids aliens and droids
all the diversity you might expect to
find at a remote port one of the last
stops before wild space every store and
restaurant will be operated by local
inhabitants making each experience
deeply immersive nothing in the land
nothing will be out of character or
stray from mythology and the land will
have two fantastic signature attractions
including the ability to take the
controls of one of the most recognizable
ships in the galaxy the Millennium
Falcon
on a customized secret mission and the
epic Star Wars adventure that puts you
right in the middle of a climactic
battle between the first order and the
resistance now with these experiences
our guests will truly become part of
their favorite Star Wars stories it will
be the first time our guests can immerse
themselves in the real physical world
that is Star Wars and one more thing
we're not just building one of these
we're building 21 disney's hollywood
studios in orlando and the other right
here in Anaheim at Disney
I
you